he is a freshly minted National Football
League quarterback drafted 10th overall
by the Arizona Cardinal and the fourth
guest on this show today which means I
guess technically we made three mistakes
here on this edition the Rich Eisen show
he's Josh Rosen how are you Josh good
how are you
you know what I'm just calling it like I
see it Josh you know me you know me yeah
I appreciate I appreciate that how's
everything been for you everything's
been awesome really good life's gone
down a bit we report to rookie minicamp
in a couple days so get a chance to kind
of breathe some fresh air slow down and
try to get back in shape and in in terms
of the the draft experience now that you
are through it you know obviously
there's making light of your comment of
nine mistakes which end you you you
divided by three because three
quarterbacks were taken before you what
was your mindset that night of the draft
when you were giving those comments Josh
you know I try to be a pretty reserved a
pretty like sort of calm calculated
personality but I got a little bit
emotional got a little frustrated but I
mean I'm gonna be honest I uh I got what
I wished for in that cat that infamous
cactus bull interview and I said I'd
rather go to the right team at a lower
pick than the wrong team at the higher
pick so I'm not staying that it any of
those teams above would be a wrong I'm
just saying that it's up to me to make
it be the right team now so I guess I
got a little bit of what I wish for and
we heard that Bradford reached out to
you he texted to you Josh yeah yeah he
did I mean honestly the whole team has
been very has been awesome
I mean I guess if you're going to you go
on a prom date you want to go with the
girl that wants to go with you
so it's kind of cool that it seemed
traded up to get me it means they really
wanted me they saw something that they
want to get out of me and that's really
exciting so I mean for the entire state
Arizona it's been an awesome reception I
mean on Twitter I get invited to throw
the first pitch the Diamondbacks game
I absolutely want to do but I mean
everyone from Larry Fitzgerald to
Patrick Peterson Chandler Jones even
foxy Justin Pugh and especially Sam
Bradford because of the imminent
competition that everyone's been
unbelievably receptive and I really
honestly couldn't have wished for a
better couple days following the dress
now it's interesting use the word
competition is that how you're viewing
your summer to come Josh yeah I mean
regardless the outcome I'm always going
to bring my best air each and every day
I mean I've said in a bunch of
interviews that I'm not going to come in
and ruffle any feathers unnecessarily I
I'm gonna be very respectful I
understand I understand the situation
we're gonna editing or hope that we
would both help each other and if he's
the starter it doesn't matter I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna help him as best as
I can because as far as I know I'm on a
four-year deal with I think a fifth and
I'm an Arizona Cardinal I'm not Josh
Rosen on on this team that is just that
I am just a part of I I am fully
immersed in the team and I want to help
this team when regardless fool eleven
are on the field Josh Rosen Cardinals
quarterback here on the Rich Eisen show
just a less than a week after being
drafted by the Arizona Cardinals so now
that you're through it now that you are
through the dreaded talent evaluation
portion of your professional career what
warrior takes on it Josh and what
improvements do you think could be made
from the prospect point of view I think
make the draft like mid like
mid-february but I think a lot of I
think as you go through the process
sometimes people start people start to
forget that yeah we're drafting someone
to play football
it ends up being micrographs and someone
a data our daughter but for the most
part it's there's a lot more to it than
you really realize from the outside
looking in I mean as a standard that I
just remember kind of watching watching
a little bit of the combine I like a
dare to Brendan scenes that some guys
are in their 40s I see some pro days pop
up every now in the video
knowing you don't really appreciate how
long and grueling of a process it is
until you're a part of it
there's just something always going on
you're never really living in one place
for more than a month or two at the same
time I'm on a lot of planes and it's
it's it's honestly it's a dream come
true but there's definitely a lot to it
and I'm just excited to get it going on
the next portion of this journey and
before we get to that I would be remiss
if I didn't ask you about the news that
came out yesterday about what alonzo
highsmith the Browns vice president and
player personnel said and his evaluation
of you and running into the UCLA
volleyball team in in an airport did you
hear about this Josh okay so what do you
think about that story that came out I
thought it's interesting you didn't talk
to my girlfriend I mean maybe he's
scared of someone actually saying
something good about me but I don't know
thought it was funny so there would have
been no red flags right I mean what
would her scouting report of you have
been Josh I don't know it's amazing that
you can pull a red flag from something
with literally zero information okay
like he literally pulled absolutely no
information from from his encounter and
it managed to be a red flag yeah I know
although we we were we were workshopping
how the volleyball coach could have said
oh you got to go talk to his girlfriend
if any negatively uh-huh gotta go talk
to I mean we couldn't even come up with
an inflection where a read flies over
there just yeah you know what I mean
yeah I mean the volleyball team yeah you
know I think it's all it's like the it's
like those children's books like with or
without the comma it's like how you read
it so maybe there maybe maybe you read
it we through without a comma it's all
in how you look all night consecutive
AIDS that's right
right like that's that could have been
it well armed rose and you gotta go talk
to his girlfriend well at least you're
through all that now now let's talk
about your new organization and part of
the reason why you're calling in today
is you got to know Todd Heap through
this process and and and through I guess
you're now a new part of the Arizona
Cardinals organization you've gotten a
chance to sit down with Todd Josh yeah
absolutely I mean honestly get getting
trapped in the NFL it's it's sort of
it's a fraternity I mean regardless of
what team even the whole NFL legends
program that they're that we get to talk
to and communicated with it's really
like an awesome family and everyone sort
of helps one another out but with Todd
Heap specifically because he's an
Arizona legend legend I've gotten pretty
close to me he's helped me at a time but
as tomorrow works we're celebrating hugs
from Holly day on behalf of his he and
his family and Todd as I said as a
legend in Arizona and meeting if the
draft was was all it was really really
cool and so basically were encouraging
everyone to wear pink and share hugs and
posting them with a hashtag hug from
Holly day and we're encouraging everyone
to perform a random act of kindness and
he and his family's honor and post it
again anywhere on on social media you
know in honor of his four-year-old who
passed away last year Todd just a good
dude
I mean Warner to Larry Fitzgerald your
your-your-your among some good human
beings Josh Rosen I'll tell you that yes
yes and and according to my Scouts
report I think I need a lot more of
those human beings in my life has Kurt
reached out to yes Kurt reached out to
you Josh yes he has and I'm actually I'm
I'm gonna call him when I get when I get
into town where works forbidden from the
state of Arizona until uh until rookie
minicamp
okay so when I get there I'm absolutely
gonna reach out to him and that's like
and that's honestly than the coolest
thing about this that's been almost over
wrongly in a
the support from ex Cardinals anyone in
the state of errors ex-football players
in the NFL it's a really really cool
family and it's it's a unique experience
that only a couple people in this world
have anything anything like that in the
sense of how scrutinized yours
professional athlete for the quarterback
in particular you know it's are pretty
amazing too before I let you go Josh
again
hashtag hugs from Holly de random acts
of kindness give someone a hug take a
picture of it posted to twitter facebook
instagram tomorrow
and and think of a heap family it just
think about it before the new stadium
gets built here you're gonna be playing
in the in the home of USC trojans once a
year Josh yes you can't quit it yeah
yeah I actually talked to Jared Goff a
little bit he's actually he's been a
really really awesome mentor through
before me through the process giving me
sort of tidbits of advice on how to get
through the whole scouting process but
it's funny how now we're playing each
other twice a year got to play them once
at Cal got the better of them but now I
get to playing twice yeah it's a pretty
it's gonna be an awesome it's gonna be
an awesome conference you got a lot of
really really great quarterbacks you got
Russell you got a Jared you have Jimmy G
you know so it'll be a lot of fun
cmeg yeah I'll never forget that time
that the Patriots pulled over the
Eastern Illinois volleyball coach and
wanted to know something about Jimmy G
and his girlfriend's uh right over there
at the at the Cinnabon go ask her what's
going on you know it's unbelievable and
look where he is today Josh so good luck
to you absolutely thank you so much for
having me on great chatting with you
don't be a stranger I know you're gonna
probably just dive into that playbook
and when you want to come up for air I'm
always here to chat absolutely
Thanks order to get in your studio and
anytime anytime thanks again Josh
Congrats on everything
all right that's Josh Rosen so Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience